هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم اختتمت القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 اعمالها باصدار البيان
الختامي الذي وافق عليه القاده ورؤساء
الوفود المشاركون في القمه واكد البيان
على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وتكثيف
الجهود للتوصل لتسويه عادل لها كما عبر عن
دعم مجلس القياده الرئاسي في اليمن لاحلال
الامن والاستقرار ودعا لتكثيف الجهود
العربيه لمساعده سوريا في تجاوز ازمتها
ولعوده اللاجئين كما دعى لانهاء الصراع
بالسودان ولحل الازمه الليبيه في الاطار
الليبي والى سرعه انتخاب رئيس في لبنان
كشف برنامج الجزيره التحقيقي ما خفي اعظم
الذي تم بثه امس الجمعه ان مسؤولا
اسرائيليا كبيرا في مكتب وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي السابق بنجانس اعترف اهلي
مسؤولين امريكيين ان الرصاصه التي قتلتها
الزميل شيرين ابو عاقله اطلقها جندي
اسرائيلي وحصل ما خفي اعظم على وثائق من
تحقيقات اسرائيليه في قضايا قتل صحفيين في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه كشفت حجم التلاعب
الاسرائيلي في التحقيقات والتهرب من
المسؤوليه والعقاب
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها دمرت
18 مسيره من طراز شاهد كانت متجهه نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وقد اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه هناك تعرض العاصمه لهجوم جوي تم
تنفيذه بعدد من المسيرات الهجوميه من طراز
شاهد مؤكده اسقاط الدفاعات الجويه كل
المسيرات في سماء المدينه
نقلت وكاله رويترز زعمنا مسؤول امريكيا ان
الرئيس جو بايدن سيعلن عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه لاوكرانيا بقيمه
375 مليون دولار اثناء وجوده في هيروشيما
في قمه قاده دول مجموعه السبعه
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
الرئيس بايدن ابلغ قاده مجموعه السبع
موافقته على تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على
طائرات اف 16 واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي عقده
على هامش القمه في هيروشيما ان تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه على الطائرات يتطلب
اشهرا وسيتم اتخاذ قرار خلال الاشهر
المقبله بشان الدول التي ستزود اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه كان
بلاده ستعمل مع الولايات المتحده وهولندا
وبيلجيكا والدنمارك لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالقدره الجويه القتاليه التي تحتاجها
اثر رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في
السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حميتي من منصب
النائب الاول لرئيس مجلس السياده واكلف
رئيس الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان مالك
عجاره بدلا منها كما اجرى تغييرات في
القياده العامه للجيش تضمنت تعيين نائبا
للقائد العام ومساعدين له
الى اللقاء